yes haridasa diocese
Unum in Mexico City and we've known each
other for several years
friend and there's some really
fascinating work put up on the ground
chasing down Jagger's and in Mexico and
radio tracking them and implementing
conservation strategies for Perry dorks
and North America as well as working at
the very broad scale doing a
conservation planning
bridging from field zoologist naturalist
all the way to macro ecology and what's
go conservation and looking forward to
some presentation thank you
well thank you very very much I'm going
to talk today about this global patterns
of mammal distribution from local and
from local I'm going to give you just
one example of what we do in Mexico and
then to global scales and I would like
to do two a pay attack to be a word I
like to make you aware that most of
these global projects looking at the
global level where animals of mammals or
birds are aware have enormous enormous
problems on trying to go down to the
regional or national level
but on the other hand are very important
to have a give us a big broad view over
the important steps towards achieving
conservation at these levels well first
of all I'm very grateful to Walter to
invite me to talk here with you and for
you for attending this meeting this is
one of the last universities I'd never
been invited to speak off and I was very
angry about it not anymore
well thank you very very much
and as we all know the global
environmental problems when I studied
biology not many years ago well
something like 25 years ago there was
only one really global environmental
problem that was the depletion of the
ozone layer now every two three weeks
every month we hear about a completely
new unforeseen global problem
environmental problem so we're really
facing what I think is a unique time and
the history of humanity were both
economic and environmental collapses are
pushing us towards a very very unknown
territory and I think about all of these
the most important one is the loss of a
biological biodiversity and in Mexico
this is a very severe problem and what
I'm going to tell you today is how I
went from very specific issues then to
global patterns and then very quickly
I'm going to tell you what we are doing
now in Mexico to try to convert all this
scientific knowledge into public
policy so basically what it motivates me
I mean what is motivates my work in real
life
is trying to save as much of species of
plants as animals as I can and once
somebody asked me why I have such a
weird I think in mind I don't know but I
mean this is what I wanted to do and
this is what I have focused all my
research and all my applications you
know we have here here that resources
for conservation are very limited and
part of the problem I think is us as a
biology psychology that we haven't been
able to explain properly to politicians
to people taking decision why it's
important to put more money into
conservation regardless of saving the
species of the plants of the animals
born in terms of human well-being and
obviously doing that will give us a
proper framework to save all the species
that we need to say and mammals
well I think that many see ok I compiled
the first a distribution map of all the
mammals of the world in 2005 it was
before IUCN and what we did is addresses
several important questions and
basically one of the most interesting
one was for the first time at least to
my knowledge we were able to see
synthetize in 2005 where were the
patterns of species distributions of all
the mammals of the world of any large
attacks on like that and while we were
an expert on mammals and what I saw here
on those maps was something that I have
I couldn't even imagine that was
happening first time there was a species
richness a Mexico very important in
terms of species richness but some areas
like here in the in the Himalayas and
even have a slightest idea that were
important and have the suspicion then
species at the risk of extinction
very interesting patterns and then this
is very very important endemic species
what we call a politically endemic
species a species restricted to one
country it's more than 2,000 species are
restricted the deal was a single country
you know and this is started to do MA
think that having this a large amount of
information synthetized could really be
a major step to understanding the
Hispanic patterns and also to use them
for foster conservation for instance
that particular graph these two graphs
having is truly important in Mexico to
increase they a budget for a protected
areas for instance for 1 million dollars
per year to more than 150 millions
dollars a year through the government
and I'm happy to tell you that the new
administration in Mexico we are going to
work closely together and we're trying
to expand the protected areas to almost
25% of the whole territory and this is a
compromise we have with a new president
plus increase in probably to almost 1
billion dollars the amount of money to
spend in and protecting the areas but
protecting the areas that sin means that
were going to fend them out is working
with the local people to empower them
and to use them so they get benefits
from from conservation so anyway
working at the global level but we
realize I realize it was a lot a lot of
species were restricted to very very
small ranges making them very prone to
extinction and then as you can see in
some of the some of my slides you will
see a species and then the name and then
a country and the year and these are all
species new to science since 2000 and
more less than ten years ago more than
600 species of mammals has been
discovered and I'm not talking about the
split of a species like the African
elephant that is considered two species
I'm talking about completely new things
like this hi monkey in Brazil this this
animal is a whole new family of mama
discovered in a market in Laos death and
there was a mother's looking at he found
it bought it and then he discover it was
a whole new species and so on so
basically what we have found is there is
lots of new species of
if we put the splits and so on and all
this a taxonomic variation there are
more than one thousand and five hundred
species who has been described or split
in the last ten years if this is
happening to mammals
just imagine what is happening to all
lower or more inconspicuous animals so
what Eric was saying that is probably
ten million species of large animals I
don't think we have really a close good
idea how many species that are but what
we know is that the largest number the
lightest percentage of a species on
earth are on the scribe and most of them
as I'm going to show you in a minute are
found in places who are highly impacted
orders have been really really fast so
what we have done before after we
discovered this species we need some
predictive world on trying to assess
where the new species of mammals and the
new species of amphibians
could be for a found and we found please
think like that you know like areas like
here in the fundus or in malaria in
Papua New Guinea and so on
so in 2011 I went to one of his
particular places as was highlighted in
my in my study as a very promising and
get work but we found is a new species
of mammals of those new alien species of
mammals some of them were rather
remarkable like at least a new monkey
with new porcupine this is the fourth
species of the shrew marsupial in North
America South America and we found the
southernmost record of a new species of
through in also in los Andes for me this
was rather remarkable for three things
first we could we have predict those
areas as important for a probably
fostering new species of mammals and
amphibians
we went to this areas and we found those
species and the fieldwork
it took us only 15 days were going back
this to time this to this year and we're
going to a new area in where we think
we're going to find out more species the
second the species are found in a in a
place in a paper park who was set aside
in Peru in 1993 for some reason
if somebody has a great idea to protect
their area it was protected now is
although it's very isolated is
surrounded by crops and dozen species
live exclusively in their area if that a
person and I say this because there is a
lot of criticism between scientists
saying that sometimes we set aside part
without not knowing what is there in
full detail obviously this person the
person who set aside this area he
understood the hater the heterogeneity
the isolation and some will be important
for the species that could Harbor and he
was right and at the third is all these
species because of the tiny range they
have should be considered in danger of
extinction and if we could have gone to
this area probably in a few years time
without
surveilling it now they probably have
become extinct without even being known
to science and this is the squat what's
happening all over the world terms of a
species are becoming extinct but we
don't know you're simply because there
are not enough scientists describing
them so what we have been doing then in
my lab at this level is looking at then
what are they royal patterns of species
distributions and so on and then we have
decided now to work on what will be some
interesting new approaches on on
addressing some of these large-scale
patterns and what can we learn about
what if species are being lost aside
from the number of a species so we have
been starting to work at this global
level with what we call the functional
ecology functional traits and that means
that we're looking not only what species
have been becoming extinct what are what
are the traits what is the collage
achill role of some of those species in
the in the places because this is
telling us not only what species is lost
but also what functions are we losing in
the environment and we're linking those
functions with what we call
environmental services there are all
those benefits that we great get for
free from nature so this is extremely
poor
because a nature of services or
environmental services has been a key a
key issue for fostering conservation in
Mexico when I talked to the Minister of
Environment of the minister of the
economy and so on about conservation
I hardly say preserving a species or
maintaining a species or biodiversity I
most of the time first explaining why
all these species are required to keep
the well-being human well-being in the
country why are they important to
maintain productivity where they are
important to face a global warming in
terms of food production and then we can
easily relate to why we should keep it
as a species going and it has been
extremely useful for me to be able to
use that kind of thing now looking at
this and I'm not going to go into detail
but if basically this is a global
distribution of krabit richness across
the core regions in the world and we're
having here to rest all mammals aquatic
arboreal ball and for soil and so on we
have a big database on that and the
information that we're getting that from
that it's very very promising very very
interesting this is one example at the
global level and this is a paper is
going to be published in a PNA yes and
then this is something a little bit more
detail looking at the same patterns in
Africa you know so looking at those big
patterns Casa allow me three things
specifically one is to understand where
the distribution of a species are and
trying to link it to more environmental
issues like what are the determinants in
terms of a temperature or precipitation
and so on what is the relationship of
those distributions to for instance
human impacts and third to try to have a
Bream's an idea of what will be the
area's important for conservation and
here I will also warn again
that this is simply a way to visualize
it in this particular case what we read
in our paper in 2005 was that we asked
this question what we need to preserve
10% of all the geographic ranges of the
mammoths of the world
and what we found is like having that
goal will demand a huge area roughly
four-point-three percent of the ice a
three land surface of the earth and this
is extremely extremely important this is
just mammoths imagining we need to put
on top birds reptiles amphibians water
fright water fishes fresh water whatever
it means that practically on earth or
the surface of that should be protected
to save all the species obviously does
that's impossible yes well we find here
also is something less extremely
important in 2002 I published a paper in
which we say that a species extinction
is extremely bad but populations
extinction is terrible because if we
have Jaguars for instance in Mexico and
we lost Jaguars in Mexico it doesn't
matter that we have the species in
Brazil because the role that the species
is playing in the original in Mexico is
lost and what losing so many of those
species so in this particular case for
instance when we find out that in each
one of these 10,000 expertly lammeter
cells we consider each representation of
a mammal in an area like that as a
population what we're looking at here is
we will be protecting here more than
100,000 populations of mammals so what
we look then is what percentage of those
AAA sales that are required to protect
the 10% of the mammals were already
impact by human activities and it is
really really interesting because what
we find that eighty percent of the land
area that is required
to protect those species has to be
managed you know then - he's already
been managed and it has been impact by
agriculture 80% of the cells that are
important to protect the 10% of the
Mamas are already impact by agriculture
and at least 20% of the self who were
critical for conservation mammals were
mostly gone by agriculture and let me
remind you that we are now 7 billion
people and probably the future of our
University will depend on a couple of
things on energy on the fate of food
production and we have seen already that
this is a huge acute problem already and
this is will become even worse so we
need to find out ways to couple
development and conservation and this
kind of tools are helping us a lot then
we have a push over studies towards the
marine things and within the same same
analysis of the marine mammals and we
came out with this information in which
we call the priority sites for
conservation of the marine mammals and
we found basically this areas are
extremely important where the Japanese
the New Zealand South Africa and African
and so on are important because of their
species richness there are tremendous
important because they Harbor a lot of
the mammal species massive species of
the world and then what we have here is
places that we call irreplaceable and
these places have a species found
nowhere else
so in this particular case this can be
important guidance for focusing
conservation and when we published this
paper I got a letter from the Minister
of the Environment from Russia the one
on Peru and the one from New Zealand
requesting most information because they
were very interested because of this
paper on having some public policy
affecting conservation on this
particular area for instance the
Russians were extremely keen to see the
the Baikal area was important because of
its an endemic seal over there
the only fresh water is
on the wall and then with one of the my
colleagues like a Anna Davison here
we're having working on trying to
predict and trying to see where are the
traits that make a species more prone to
extinction and one thing that a paper
that hasn't catch up yet properly but I
want to push it a little bit more is
that with Anna what we found it like a
set of rules of thumb of gold in which
we can know now we can tell you what
size everybody says that size is a
predictor of extinction in mammals we
can tell you now very precisely at what
level what's what wait
it makes a species more prone to
extinction and we can also tell you we
certain a lot of detail what arboreal
species are Mark's a prone to extinction
to fossil species and so on and we have
done this for for threatened mammoths
and we have done this for marine mammals
of the world and what we have found is
like this very very interesting patterns
so what are the most important things
affecting the extinction risk like body
mass like taxonomic groups and so on but
also what we have found is that there
are several species of mammals of marine
mammals right now are not considering
extinct or threatened or a vulnerable
but they have all the characteristics
required by to be considered like that
and they are probably not being
considered on being in danger with
extinction simply because there is not
enough information available so this is
a kind of predictive analysis and then I
did this with water yet and basically
with water we have done is like what
species or what groups could be used as
surrogate and just to give you this very
briefly is bat and rodents explain 72
percent of the mammal species of the
world if you know whether the mama you
know what are the rodents for instance
of the Watson area you can know
perfectly well what are the other
species and you can play around with
this kind of things
well this is some of the concluding
remarks I have on the brother large
scale thing and then what I'm going to
explain the last two minutes here is to
let you know what I think that three
most important things I have ran with
these studies first this taking
advantage of this large database and the
powerful computing and analysis methods
that we have now is extremely powerful
to understand issues that otherwise are
basically impossible to understand
second that looking at the global level
is important to give you guidelines but
is almost it will be useless or
impractical to go from the global level
to a country level to watch a country
level you have to work with much more
detailed data on that level you know
first I don't like the idea of
prioritizing species and saying that
we're going to save these species of
alien species or that we're putting a
lot of money in the gap and issue
conservation in the real world doesn't
work doesn't work that way the money has
had been allocated to call California
California condor for instance that
there is a lot of criticism that this
money should have been gone to somewhere
else if the that money should have been
put into the California condor it would
probably have been put in a highway
somewhere in the country so so I think
the prioritization goes in a different
way the prioritization should go and
understanding at a more country level
issue what are important and critical
factors affecting species and then try
to link those two on the one thing
public policy how do we convert our
science into public policy and second to
make the link with conservation and
development because in Mexico the best
the most important the long-term
conservation issue that we have been
able to raise are the ones where we have
been able to take one and group of
species or one problem link it to
development and the
producing a solution that on the one
hand will keep the system going tomorrow
mental system going the plant and the
animals and the cohesion and on the
other hand will provide solutions for
the local people for benefiting the
local people and for the regional and
the national economy and I think these
are one of the critical critical issues
that we have to address here and thank
you very very much for your attention
well yes yes yes to finish them let me
tell you that we have been able in
Mexico I do basic science but we have
been able to do really quantum leap in
conservation because since the last 20
years we have an endangered species act
we have a new the National sisters of
protected areas we have a specific goals
and with this new government we have
have created a social movement is called
Mexico the environmental revolution that
is pushing forward to have a specific
objective like zero deforestation and
rate in protected areas at the end of
this sixth term year we're looking at
what are the problems causing the first
station and then we're looking at a
specific solution that the government
national government can do and turn into
public policy and I think linking
conservation linking basic science with
conservation and then with a important a
coupling it with development is one of
the most promising ways to try to stop
the massacre what we're doing with a
species extinction and just to finish
let me tell you that we just have
probably what I think is the most
important the most conservative but also
solid analysis of the extinction rates
on vertebrates and the data shows that
were losing species at the rate probably
between 20 to 120 times faster than the
background rate and this means that the
last species that we have lost in the
last 100 years Chuck has been law should
have been lost naturally between 1,000
to 15,000 years thus the magnitude of
this terrible crisis of extinction of
species thank you